good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the mid-suffolk
development control committee V mayor
first of all please read some domestic
arrangements please do not interrupt
other speakers or hold separate
conversations whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or Switched Off we will be using
e-voting for this meeting on the modern
gov app so please could members make
sure they are logged in and ready to use
the app
fire safety Arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
the fire exit make your way to the
assembly Point Ipswich Town Football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium which is the
ground floor area and walkways if you're
in the atrium at the time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it is safe to do so the council members
of the public and press May film record
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
so we go on to introductions we have the
area planning manager Gemma Walker
we have the legal advisor in Dupre and
the case officers Amelia Powell and
Jasmine wired and Martha Cavani the
governance officer Elizabeth Alicia
Norman
we have the ward members present
wherever they are John Whitehead and
councilor Andrew Mellon although on the
committee will move when he speaks as
Ward member and Bethany who's driving
RIT today and Mandy who's back up
so we also have members of the committee
here we have councilor Muller councilor
Gould and then coming on the back row
Council of War boys Council of stringer
councilor Mallon councilor Norris and
councilor Caston in that order coming
down and they will be looking to make a
decision today on the applications
before us can I have apologies for
absence and substitutions please
thank you chair none received
to receive any Declarations of
disclosable pecuniary interests or other
registerable interests or
non-registerable interests by members
cancer Stringer yeah thank you I have a
personal prejudicial opportunity
interest in item D and I will be leaving
the room and taking no part in that
debate thank you very much for that
decorations of lobbying any to declare
you know
Declarations of personal site visits any
to declare
you know
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of September
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes please
no may I have a proposal and a seconder
for the minutes please proposal Council
Caston secondary councilor Norris
we will now have an electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
are some people having difficulty in
getting the boat through
councilor Norris has your vote gone
through on your screen
do you want me to take your vote
verbally please
are you for the minutes for us please
the vote hasn't gone through
electronically
the vote hasn't gone through
electronically are you for it
thank you thank you very much for that
the computers are a little slow today
thank you Council of War boys
you've done it thank you
they are taking some time thank you for
that thanks so thank you chair that
makes five votes four and three
abstentions so the minutes are carried
thank you very much I'll sign them later
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received here
so the schedule of planning applications
what I'm going to do because we have
some members of the public here for the
second application that we had on our
list we will do that one first so the
order of play will now be
machine
button
no no yes the order will be 7B will be
first
and then we'll have 7A
and then we'll have
70 7D and to announce that the 7c
dc2106824 land at fenings Farm pixie
green stradbroke will not be heard that
has been withdrawn
so we have three today so there we are
so moving on to the agenda
so what will happen now for those of you
who haven't been here before is the case
officer will present the case to us and
members of the committee will have the
opportunity just a question for clarity
something they're not quite clear on
what they've read in the papers or heard
today but they're usually pretty
comprehensive in information we already
have we have questions from members and
then we move on to public speakers and
the public speakers will have three
minutes and we have
the timer
we have a really electronic timer here
it's like an egg timer
so you can boil your eggs
is it there anyway we'll find one or
something at the time and you get three
minutes and everybody um who is a public
speaker will be allowed three minutes
and not a second more
so moving on and then after that we then
go into debate and then come to a
conclusion of the application so moving
on
um we've got
second case which is
land at pipsford and Jasmine will
introduce the case for us thank you very
much
thank you chair and good morning members
I'm presenting a full planning
application today which can be broken
down into two key elements firstly the
change of use of land to a construction
agricultural training facility which
includes the erection of a training
center building and other Associated
buildings secondly the change of use of
land for private equestrians
agricultural purposes including the
erection of stables and other ancillary
buildings
members are reminded that this
presentation should be viewed in
conjunction with the committee report
this presentation does not and cannot
replace the content within that report
here is the site in its wider context
shown by the area outlined in red the
site Falls wholly within the ward of
Clayton and Barham and Falls within the
Parish of codnan
zooming in the site again is shown in
Red so as you can see you have the A14
just the East agricultural land the
North and South a cluster of dwellings
Southwest and the river gipping and
Gallows Hill Quarry and sandworkings to
the West
here is the submitted site location plan
showing access to be taken from an
existing access on the Beacon Hill
roundabout which is subject to upgrades
as part of this application
so in terms of planning history this
application is a resubmission of an
earlier refused application there were
four reasons for refusal included which
were relating to insufficient Justified
need
landscape impacts noise impacts and
insufficient flood risk and drainage
information
reshufficient addresses the previous
insufficient areas
clear justification and business case
has now been supplied clarifying the
operations on site
additional landscape assessments and
mitigation has been provided
and also proposed noise impacts have
been subject of further assessments and
these are now acceptable in regards to
our statutory quantity being
environmental health
finally flood risk and drainage
information has now been supplied
as such and as reflected in the
recommendation the planning balance has
shifted as a result of this additional
information now being provided
so the applicant is provided a short
drain footage clip panning over the site
which is useful to give you an idea of
the site in its real context
I think this is going to work
it won't work no
okay
I can't see that one
that one which one is it that one no
okay
that's why we have any time
I'm not sure why it's not working
oh okay amazing thank
you I think right so here is the Drone
footage
so the following two slides contain site
photos as well so the directions that
these photos were taken is shown on the
central map
uh the Stars show specific things just
to bring to members attention
so number one is looking towards the
Northwest with the star showing the
river gipping
number two looks northwards through the
site and the star shows where the
training center is proposed
as you can see the site slopes down
towards the West
number three looks towards the southwest
corner of the site as you can see there
is an existing boundary fence and the
star shows where the nearest residents
are to the site again you can see other
site slopes towards the West
and number four look Southeast towards
the proposed equestrian area of the site
the star shows where the Stables would
be
here are further site photos so again
um number one shows the proposed access
into the training area of the site the
star again shows where the training
facility would go
number two shows the access road off of
the roundabout that will be subject to
the upgrades as you can see the A14 is
just adjacent beyond the trees
number three again looks towards
Southwest uh the star again shows where
residents are and number four looks
through the site again the star shows
the proposed training building notably
there is a dense mature Woodland running
along the northern boundary of the site
so sorry let's see if this one works
this is another video yeah that should
work
um so this is a video to give you an
idea of the background noise as existing
on site
um as you should be able to hear the
traffic noise from the A14 is prominent
and notably this resubmission has been
supported by additional noise
information to overcome one of the
previous reasons for refusal so I'd just
reiterate that
is it not working oh okay
so unfortunately excuse me can you just
explain what it was you were trying to
demonstrate yet so in terms of that
video and it was really to give you an
idea of the background noise that you
can hear when you stand on site which is
primarily the A14 traffic
foreign
so in terms of the constraints the site
comprises of grade four agricultural
land the site partially Falls within
flood zones two and three to the western
side uh well to the Northwest as you can
kind of see by the blue
um hatched area the site is within the
gipping valley special landscape area
and there are public rights away that
run through the site and along the west
notably the public right-of-way that
runs through the site is obstructed but
it's obstructed further to the north
outside of the site
so in terms of the training to be
delivered um this is all to be delivered
by qualified instructors in accordance
with awarding bodies all those
completing courses will be issued
certificates
um photo licenses as appropriate in
accordance with those awarding bodies
construction training services is an
established local business which is
embedded locally working alongside a
range a range of businesses within the
district and surrounding areas
it's projected that between 150 and 200
candidates would visit a week a year
after its opening
this is an expansion of the existing
business with figures based on
registered demand
providing a facility which
so this the idea of the the actual
scheme is provide a facility which
accommodates training needs and the
needs of the awarding bodies and plugs a
gap locally in the delivery of this type
of training
the reason this site has been chosen is
primarily because of the land
composition and its accessibility the
land composition does mean that it can
be used all year round
so here's the proposed site plan in full
showing both parts of the proposal I
will break this down so you can kind of
see the specific annotations on the
plans in the coming slides
the site is split as shown by the
central pink line the majority of the
site will be used for private
small-scale Agricultural and equestrian
use with the Northern Area being for the
training facility which is where the
majority of the operational development
is going
and I've listed the key elements The
Proposal in the different areas on
screen
and as I say all operational development
is towards the east of the site the
northeast of the site nearest to the A14
and away from neighboring properties
in terms of the overall built form on
site it is kept to a minimum and is
primarily in the northeast corner and
the training center if I just get sorry
I can move the laser up again
brilliant so you've got the training
center just here then you've got the
container storage is this building here
and then you've got areas of hard
standing which is all around here and
the uh telehandler Tower is around here
and again you can see there are this
would be the kind of Access Road into
the site internally you've then got the
existing access road which was shown on
the earlier photos running along here
and you've got car parking areas kind of
either side with some temporary cabins
along here which would be removed kind
of a year after opening
and you've also got the sud space and in
the center there and the rest of this
will remain undeveloped as kind of a
grass training area
so the training center building itself
would be single story and low scale
adopting the appearance of a traditional
agricultural building in scale and in
regards to materials
PV panels are also Incorporated along
the roof
so in terms of the the telehandler tower
whilst it is taller than the uh training
building as you'll see in a later Slide
the land levels and its structure
overall assist in reducing its
prominence within the site
so again in terms of the container
storage this is what is proposed for
storing equipment on the site which was
in that North North corner
so here with post site sections looking
through at the training center as you
can see the tele Handler is at that
lower is at at that lower level on the
site
um you've also got the um Landscaping
that I'll show you in later slides so
you've got this
um kind of Earth bond which will run
along the um western boundary of the
site
um
so in terms of the proposed equestrian
use of the site so this is the southern
portion there is not much operational
development proposed in this area save
for the storage shed and Stables which
are so you've got the Stables there and
the storage shed
and it will remain free as kind of
grazing land
so here is the stable building PV panels
are also proposed on this roof and it
drops again a traditional appearance
there will also be a small area of
storage for horse manure
um
so again his proposed storage shed which
as you can see is smaller than stable
block and again is characteristic of
what you'd expect from a storage shed
so here we have the section plans
looking through the site at the stable
block and storage shed
um again you can see how it
the site slopes down and towards West
here are the images of the existing
access which is shown by that yellow
star so looking along the Well from The
Beacon Hill roundabout
the access is to be taken off of that
roundabout by the existing access with
the access which is subject to upgrades
and these upgrades will be shown in the
next slide
so there is rather a lot of technical
detail on the the plans which I've tried
to summarize
um just on the screen these upgrades
have been subject to amendments and
review in accordance with input from
National highways and Suffolk County
Council highways so they have been
reviewed by both and who both raise no
objections subject to conditions but in
effect the existing access route in
would be widened to five and a half
meters
um which is along this bit along here
and there will be increased signage up
both uh here
on uh next to the access and along here
just to basically signposts that don't
go any further than here and this is
where the the access is into the
training site which will be further kind
of round and the existing access point
and Junction so if I just scroll one up
um
this existing axis is to be widened in
accordance with Suffolk County council's
standards
which will then obviously increase
visibility around
um and you've also got some relocation
of national highways fencing and a
lighting column as well which we pushed
further back and again in terms of
replacement trees and hedgerows they
will also be pushed further back and
there will be a splitter island in the
middle
which will again then be joined by a
left turn
um Arrow marking on the road and also uh
and there's some um a Chevron that's
going to be put here as a sign just
again to reinforce it is left turn on
the roundabout
so in terms of the Landscaping the
following slides detail the Landscaping
enhancements that are proposed on the
site these will have an ecological and
biodiversity benefit improving upon the
relatively open and on landscaped
agricultural land there would be a
mixture of grass areas utilizing Wetland
Meadow and wild Wildflower mixes
alongside trees and hedges
this slide is looking at the northwest
corner adjacent to the proposed hard
standing and telehandler area just there
and you can see where the suds Basin
starts as well
um so moving to the center of the site
this is along this is where the proposed
Earth bun will run along the western
boundary of the site
finally we have the Landscaping along
the southern boundary of the site which
will be either side of the stable block
whilst soft landscaping and Boundary
treatments are proposed as noted within
the committee report there will be a
level of moderate adverse landscape
impact that cannot be mitigated however
this will reduce with time and as the
Landscaping obviously inevitably matures
and establishes moreover this harm we'll
be localized to the site and immediate
surroundings and doesn't go any further
than that
so in terms of the overall planning
balance there would be some conflict
with the development plan arising from
localized but moderate adverse landscape
impact and a low level of um Heritage
harm
however there would be significant
public benefits arising from the scheme
and overall the development when looking
at the basket policies would Accord the
development would Accord with the
development plan when taken as a whole
so the recommendation is therefore to
Grant planning permission including the
conditions within the committee report
and tabled papers thanks for listening
thank you very much I mean I've got
several questions but I'll let the
committee go first and see if I can
knock them off one by one in case you've
got the same thoughts as myself so does
anyone have any questions for the
officer
Council War boys then councilor Stringer
please thank you
forgive me if I've missed it
um there's a couple of points in the
notes about it looks as though the site
is obviously tended to be off grid where
you it's been run on a generator until
the teaching Center is built and then it
will be the photovoltaic cells that
Supply the power
uh the other question that breaks my
mind is is water connected to the site
and has there been any information about
sewage and
and a report from Anglia Waters if I've
missed it I apologize but uh
uh thank you so in terms of the
um I suppose how it's being run to start
with and so there would be a temporary
diesel generator it is temporary and the
PV panels are then intended to kind of
uh supersede that as it were
um in terms of the sewage arrangements
and water connections I don't believe
we've had any information on that being
may like to ask the applicant who will
be more
um aware of the the kind of utility
arrangements with it
okay so I'll ask the developments thank
you
thank you a couple of questions
um first of all the site area uh 3.3
hectares uh I've seen the report what
grade of land this is
um we normally get told what we're
losing from agriculture as it were yes
yeah um I do believe it is in the report
it's great for just for the audience to
doubt though fine the the other part the
description the title
this land at the moment is agricultural
land you don't need to apply for
planning mission to gray sheep
so I I was confused as to why that was
in the title it's more um I suppose for
clarity we can tweak the description
obviously as you say rightfully say it's
agricultural land it doesn't need
permission for sheep grazing I think the
issue is because there's an equestrian
yeast mixed in and that's the element
that needs the planning permission so
that's why it's kind of just for clarity
more than anything confirmed is kind of
being a mixture of Agriculture slash
equestrian use on that part
right so so what difference then would
it make
what I'm what I'm thinking is if if then
the implementation is there are only
horses there
would they be in breach of anything it
just seems very confusing to have
something that's permitted development
mixed in with something that's asking
for development
that seems very messy to me uh you could
probably come in there um I think we
think from my side would be if they
if they and then they go as Horses there
yeah it would have reverted back to
agricultural land and then they would
need another consent for the horses
whereas by putting both in the
description it gives them the option
essentially so it remains flexible
between the horses and the Sheep it does
not require either or both
I'm even that more confused because okay
no that covers them oh the other thing
yeah just one other thing we've got
generators proposed to be used we've got
obviously Machinery that's going to be
used to train people where is the fuel
for those Vehicles being stored
uh that is not something I'm entirely
aware of You may wish to ask the
applicant
um we can obviously you know if members
wished uh there might be by way of kind
of condition that might be something we
can get the details of via condition
councilman
yeah right Emma no it's not working
sorry about that
um yeah it's a question about
um
noise primarily
um in the papers it mentions about
obviously this is a training facility
people will be learning how to use a
telehandler and so forth but it also
talks about because of the noise from
the reversing beepers or what we call
them but those will be switched off now
that immediately to me had a kind of
health and safety implication if you're
training people how to use these
machines surely
uh the Beeper should be switched on
uh otherwise there's a danger so I just
wanted to clarify that aspect a bit
because they seem to be saying we're
going to turn them off in other places
that said there'd be a white noise
beeper
um can we just sort of understand
exactly what's going on with that thank
you yes of course obviously the training
will have to be delivered in a
so in turn
into leaping noises and that are
associated with those machines and I
probably would
kind of
um I suppose revert that question to the
applicant and because they will be aware
of how they're going to be running that
kind of facility and obviously the
health and safety elements of it as well
um in terms of the existing business
operations again I'd probably revert
that question to the applicant yep
um and what surface um I mean I don't
know whether it's the lovely heavy clay
that I sit on uh you can't use that all
year round but um what surface is going
to be put down for the area of
maneuverability Etc
um so in terms of the the actual land
composition just taking your first kind
of point and I think the idea was that
this is a um
chalk based piece of land so in terms
obviously that that has
um
better drainage than clay
um and in terms of the hard standing uh
I believe I mean I apologize if I've
missed them no that's um that's fine I
believe it was written in the report but
you might have to give me a couple of
minutes just to find the details about
that yeah
um do any neighboring properties use the
current Side Road at all
do you mean the access point in yes
that's used by them so it's shared yes
it is yeah do we know by how many
properties
um I can ask the parish council again so
you don't know yes I don't want to trip
you up no no that's that's absolutely
fine there is a cluster of them it's not
just
the one yeah I
typic number right okay
um originally you said container storage
and I thought what they're going to
stock
for but and I wrote height but obviously
it's for the equipment so be one height
container with equipment in it one
presumes yes yes we can always condition
that they're not stacked and if that's
something's wish as well um on slide 20
um you said the horse manure um will be
stored where is it going to be removed
and how is it going to be removed
removed and when is it going to be
removed and is it near a Watercourse
um I don't think we have any of the
details on the dispose at the minute
that is when we deal with normal
equestrian-based applications we do
normally condition details of that for
environmental health to review which
includes whether there's so we might
have to add a condition on we could add
a condition on to that yes if members
are minded too yes and on slide 20. how
many Stables are there there please
there are three Stables
um shown with attack room storage area
and washroom
um and you say the access will be
improved to five and a half meters from
what length is the access going to be
widened to five and a half meters do we
know
um I probably would have to check the
plans for the specific length but in
effect
um I don't know if I can get presumably
working RC agent as well but presumably
just to the entrance of the news so in
facility basically the the entrance
width
um which when you come from the junction
I guess and that is to be widened more
than the five and a half meters but when
you go down the access track that would
then be widened to five and a half
meters right past the construction
facility turning past yeah and then it
reverts back to the kind of existing
right that's sort of I'll keep a couple
of them for other people that's
um I did note
um that it's probably more for debate
um okay I'll use some of those questions
that I put to you
some stage
um we'll use them in debate so
I'll now
invite
the parish council
Nick Mills if you'd like to have three
minutes and um give us your views on
this particular application please thank
you
good morning councilors
um codden Parish Council remains firmly
of The View
that this revised application
for development is an inappropriate site
as per its submissions previously made
it stands Foursquare with the preps
forward residence which is seven
households
you use that access road
and their objections to a change that
will destroy immunity and bring constant
noise increased noise and I think the
noise that was mentioned earlier which
we didn't hear
was actually on the site not where they
are at the bottom of the slope
as the increased noise there that's the
important thing and light pollution and
we mustn't forget light pollution to
what is a tranquil Hamlet including a
listed farmhouse
Parish councilors first and foremost ask
members to get very careful
consideration to the adverse impact this
proposal has on the residence of
Pitchford
this section of the gipping valley is an
important green Link in the parish which
will soon be enhanced by the
Naturalization of previous sites of
gravel extraction
responses to a recent Parish survey
conducted by all voluntary and
charitable bodies as well as the parish
council over 50 percent of households
within the parish responded highlighted
the importance of green spaces and green
links nature and walking both to the
physical and mental well-being of
residents they also bring into the
parish like-minded people who use
condoms facilities some from adjoining
areas and many from further afield
the parish council has a clear mandate
to support maintenance and development
of which naturally environment and
footpaths working with adjacent Parish
councils will need a market Town Council
as an aside I understand that public
footpath number 27 has been obstructed
by lock gates for more than two years
and the sign put up by the public rights
away Department removed
this was in regular use by residents and
visitors alike prior to being blocked
off
scheme is an odds with the Mandate the
Parish of the parish residents
as a final point the parish council has
seen nothing in the application to
address the concerns of increased
vehicle access onto the A14 Junction 51
roundabout
this development will only add to what
is already a near-miss hotspot between
the East-West slip Road off the A14 and
the Needham Market exit from the
roundabout
I've heard what's been said in the last
few minutes
the residents do not see this as a way
forward
set against these clear negatives we
have one pro as we see it a limited
employment opportunity when we are close
to fully employment locally
a parish council is fully supportive of
upskilling but this can be provided
either in a manner that it doesn't
damage the amenity of residents and an
important Suffolk level green Corridor
by provision being either peripatetic
or it being delivered at a more
appropriate location
you're now on the end of the three
minutes thank you thank you very much
indeed do members have questions please
thank you very much oh yes counselor
Gould
if if I may and um you said about the
public right-of-way being blocked off
is that been
by the County Council or has it
set them through some other means being
being blocked off I'm told by the
residents it's been blocked off by
offense by a gate a locked gate
right but that's not
either is that by the County Council not
of my understanding though okay
okay if you would like to have your
three minutes please thank you very much
nowhere in the report is it mentioned
that seven families reside here do our
lives not matter
which is one thing to make written
application and state facts and figures
but it's a vast difference between
writing something and actually living it
the noise report does not reflect our
lived experiences to date the problem
with the noise that will emanate from
this proposal five and a half days per
week is one of persistence and
detrimental to anyone living in the
vicinity
during Kobe the applicant laid a
hardcore area using just one Digger and
one roller the vibration that traveled
through the ground could be both heard
and felt inside the home and during this
very hot period we had to keep all
windows and doors closed it became like
an ear worm the current access from the
A14 a140 interchange is dangerous to say
the least there's not one person who
uses our access that has not had many
near-misses when leaving the roundabout
and indicating to turn left the majority
of other drivers assume the indication
is to turn off to need a market
approaching from the slip Road of the
A14 also gives this impression there are
regular rear end shunts occurring that
do not get reported and therefore any
accident report is going to be
inaccurate experience versus
documentation
public transport there is no public
transport the nearest is in need a
market one and a half miles away and
there are no Pathways for the public
moreover public transport to and from
need a market is limited with very poor
connections
the report States the site is next to a
gravel Quarry gravel extraction has
ceased an important Nature Reserve is
currently under construction the
proposed development have a very
negative effect on the fragile ecology
and biodiversity and be of significant
visual detriment particularly as only
the river gipping divides the reserve
from the proposed development the peace
and Solitude of the Riverwalk attracts
many visitors from across the county and
Beyond
the report states there are three other
training sites within 50 Mr radius but
they cannot offer an outdoor year-round
facility again incorrect they do
it is stated it will be at least 15
years before the planned Landscaping
will begin to mitigate the visual
problems associated with this Venture
why was it not proposed to plant mature
trees which although expensive is
entirely possible
in conclusion the officer States The
Proposal does not comply with a
development plan as a whole with regard
to the significant landscape harm and
approval of the application would
strictly represent departure from the
plan the only permitted development
within a special landscape designated
area is agricultural or forestry and
despite the smoke and mirrors this is
not an agricultural proposal
so I would ask which is more important
the preservation of our Countryside and
ecology or financial gain
given the evidence it seems clear it'd
be irrational to approve there are
numerous material errors in the planning
officers report it is also believed
there are a lack of sufficient reasons
to approve or explanations to why this
proposal is a unique and exceptional
circumstances it is felt that these
points alone would give grounds for
seeking a judicial review
does anyone have questions
councilman
um so my question is around access I
couldn't fully understand from the the
plans we have shown but your access to
your properties and the other six
is sort of along the top end of the song
when you come off can I interrupt you
both can I ask the officer to put the
overhead view on because the overhead
view would show us where you would be
could you put words up please sorry
counselor and uh Mrs Parker sorry no
thanks that's very useful
and get the right one
okay when when you leave the roundabout
and turn onto the access road there's a
small apron which is owned by the County
Council and they have to maintain that
I'm I'm very aware of this because in
the past I'm the person that has sought
to get the access made up and there's
been potholes there but after that
initial apron it comes into an almost
single Track Road and as far as I was
aware that was owned by the farmer
because he tarmacs it from there on down
now whether there's an agreement in
place or whether you can just upload
somebody else's ground I don't know but
it becomes if you are coming up to go
out and somebody's coming down somebody
has to move from one side or another
so it's really difficult your access is
this sort of basically parallel to the
A14 exactly exactly you come parallel
down and then you turn right
um at the end of the row of trees and
you don't own that that's you have a
right of access it's a right-of-way
everything is
custom yes
yes thank you very much
um in April 2018 there was a serious
accident on that
um Junction could you tell me anything
about that well I wasn't present at the
time obviously but but um there's
actually been more than one in fact I
think probably one of my colleagues can
give you better information but
um am I allowed to refer
red I would like the best information
possible I don't know the exact answer
but there may be one in 2018 I know
there was one also I think a bit near a
time because of kovid one always thinks
of last year you had to put these two
years in between it
um but there was another serious
accident that maybe the one you're
referring to underneath the the bridge
where Laurie turned over but there have
been a few others as well
I I mean I've had
experienced different people yeah
um I wouldn't mind knowing the details
of that because that looks like that
accident was right on that Junction
absolutely it was it was exactly
underneath somebody just can't believe
they're coming down
40. yeah
sorry do we not have the crash
can we just a second can we just look at
look at that for the time being and see
if we can come back on that
um so
shall we move on
have we finished with the questions yes
yes please may I just ask
with your permission that's the parish
council the the the the footpath that's
been blocked by the erection of the gate
is that a permissive path
is it one that's
what I'm asking is is it is it are you
suggesting there's been an unlawful act
or is it just it is a public
right-of-way okay well there are things
that can be done about that sort of
thing obviously
so can we move on to the applicant while
you're looking for the crash map details
for us would that be appropriate in do
you think we can move on to the
applicant
um and so we have Daniel Carr uh
construction training services and Nigel
I believe Nigel Carr as well
um you still only have three minutes so
if you want to be a double act please do
it
very much you have three minutes thank
you morning everyone first of all one of
the big considerations we've taken is
some of the points raised by the
residents so initially we moved the
training center from the south to the
north
the small amount of vibration mentioned
was literally a day so the activity
would not generate the noise at the
fence line from the commercial aspect
that's why it's at the north of the site
so the noise readings we have are along
the boundary to confirm that we wouldn't
cause nightmare to the neighbors I'm
very sympathetic to what the neighbors
are concerned with or if I was a
resident I would also think the same so
we listened to them we've had expensive
reports to confirm what we're doing is
not going to block their lives at all
one of the grand compositions is so
important as Jasmine has mentioned chalk
does not retain water other training
facilities may have a calendar open date
of 12 months believe me I've been a
freelancing structure for 20 years a
majority of local training centers are
in exactly the type of land we're
talking about but they are in heavy clay
with our climate change three to four
months you cannot run a full commercial
training portfolio my current business
at the moment has had the ability to use
a very temporary location that is now
gone our business
to grow and develop our industry is
short of 200 000 workers there are loads
of reports for the construction sector
loads of reports from the agricultural
sector backed up by trade bodies we are
in a skills crisis as I'm sure people
appreciate okay just because the country
has full employment that's a very
general way of looking at it we're very
we're looking at two skilled areas
construction and agriculture so that's
why the skill shortage is very desperate
and very real to answer the question
about Services there is a main water
main that runs along the Conifer line so
we can connect onto that we will use a
Clive Jester system so we will treat the
waste in the actual local environment
initially we will set up with a tank
which I have pumped out by a local
company of liaise with BT there is a
phone line access which will not have a
negative effect on a residence because
we could in uh up that with boosters so
every possible thing that I would look
at as a resident we've addressed
soundproofing buns will completely
mitigate any noise we're making all the
the machines we are using will be brand
new machines Eco settings machines are
moving very quickly towards electric and
hydrogen the storage facilities for fuel
okay will be in one of the containers we
have to have for Legal compliance double
bond Deeds we're going to put it in a
container so it's not visually there and
it reduces the interaction of theft
light pollution the biggest light
pollution is need a market industrial
estate that booms across into the
residence area across the wildlife area
and into my land okay we close at winter
hours I've got photo evidence proves how
lit up need a market industrial estate
is because I've been down the land of
many many times so I would like to think
most of the considerations have been
raised we've got mitigation for the
access I think I believe there's a
little bit of unclarity the tarmac axis
road is privately owned by the farmer
what has not been mentioned so far is
there is a farm at the end so there is a
level of residency
okay
thank you
to say just conclude if you would please
rather than a complete stop
yes
so very briefly the highway England
thinks a great idea it will reduce
Excellence The Junction will be wide
enough there'll be no pulling over as
one of the residents who's rightly
concerned
if you would please not keep going sorry
conclusion
we've searched for three years this is
the best location this is the best
mitigation the industry needs it from
both points of view I I don't know what
I can say thank you
thank you very much I'm sure there's
lots of questions that we can come up
with and I hear what you say and just
you know if you can briefly answer them
um councilor Stringer I believe you yeah
thank you
forgive me if I've missed it in the
report there are if it averages out the
amount of people per day it's about
under the car parking spaces about 30
people coming a day
how many telehandlers and pieces of
equipment will those 30 people be using
if you have
20 of them will be inside the building
doing soft skills training five of them
will be outside maybe using Machinery
another five will be doing small tool
activity so we're not going to have a
field full of machines running around
constantly now I asked how many machines
you would have I'll have it would have
one telehandler
and we can risk assess out within the
awarding bodies and health and safety
the because it will be in a controlled
area so the only person in that
controlled area will be the operative
and the instructor so we are allowed
because it's it's you see this common uh
examples in other areas where you can
risk assess out and not have so the
answer to the question is one One
telephone thank you
um
you're only going to be doing one size
of telehandling yes oh I mean there's a
there's a facility in our our village
that's got about three different sizes
you'll only be doing one and we not have
debate we've got the answer to the
question we can bring that up catch up
sorry
um right any further questions councilor
Stringer
any further questions
yeah just come back to the telehander
you'll be using will be a full range yes
so it will pick up 24 foot containers
and all that no it's a construction
based telehandle that's why we have to
have a tower of a certain size typically
you find a building site right okay
thank you thank you
thank
you
um so question you mentioned about your
Mains walk connection B Team
um is this an off grid though are you
going to have an electrical uh Mains
connection or are you attempting to run
it off the uh the PVS so that the
generator is tempering in insulated
sheds until we get the PV and the
battery system once the PV and the
battery systems are in place we hope to
generate all the electricity on the site
we're not applying to then tap into UK
power networks we'll we'll go from a
soundproof generator and we'll go down
and down and down so we can get the
minimum one just to top the batteries up
in the winter due to the low PV rating
but
uh admire your ambition um how are you
going to heat the the big building
though so the building will be insulated
beyond the minimum standards so we want
to try and create an environment where
we use low-use electric heaters because
everything has changed and everything is
moved on if you look at the heater from
20 years ago to look at a heater now
there's so much more economical
so I've done calculations with the level
of PV panels we have and the measure
amount of battery storage we have to
have and we want to try and hit the
building at ambient temperature by
doubling up on insulation in the floor
for example
okay
um
so
okay slightly different question if I
made sure
yeah
sorry
so just to understand that you talked
about you switching off the reversing
beeper so there won't be the noise but
elsewhere and it talks about sort of
what White Noise beeper
um and you say that's permissible yes
it doesn't affect health and safety no
because you're using a machine in
excluded areas so you're not having
pedestrians walking around in that area
where you would commonly have a
reversive bleeper okay
um okay another question if that's okay
um uh you've talked about having a
chargester
um in in the in the papers it talks
about you'd need a permit either from
the Suffolk drainage board or from the
environment agency if you're going to
discharge the water from that into a
river what's the plan there so initially
it'll be a tank then we'll apply for the
permit once we get the permit we'll put
the progester system in
that's all I have for now chair thank
you
the questions counselor Kirsten thank
you
I think I know the answer to this
question but I just if you could just
confirm nobody will bring their own
machine to the
to train on no right okay and um does
your machine in the training process
does it work under load
as in with weight on it
depending on what machine is being used
so they will that's why we run them in
eco mode not full power
but will you be lifting weight around or
is it literally just putting carriages
in certain places no the tele handle
will have to do a various of activities
low level and the various activities on
the on the telehander training Tower
which no person will have access to
okay so represent a building site
activity or an agricultural use yeah
um I noticed in the papers that you're
planning to run a bus from need a market
railway station
um is that just going to run at the
beginning of the end of the day or will
that be yes that's fine yeah so let's
look at as the business grows we'll have
a pick up in the morning and drop off in
the evening all the afternoon
thank you
um you say that I've taken everyone's
finished with the questions yeah you say
that um
you've looked elsewhere and this is the
best site is there anything on the site
there now apart from what you've visibly
dug out no so it's a field basically
what about the industrial sites that are
all over the county on the a12 A14 and
such like why have they not been looked
at I'll try and answer that as quickly
as I can no just very quickly you have
or you have yes oh yeah we've looked at
multiple sites for over three years
this is quite um yes a
Pacific yes I think right
um you've said about soundproofing buns
that's engineering work have you got
permission for that it's in the plans
that's that's the diagram that shows the
landscape we're just going to put an
undulating band to create a buffer when
I had the noise results down at the
boundary line technically I don't need
it because the noise dissipates the A14
overalls any noise we will generate
locally
um
and
what do you do now
so
again I'll try and be we just quite
quickly yes so we do some activities on
site under one awarding body but the
main awarding body will not allow you to
do anything unless you've got a training
sensor do you mean on site that this
application site no no no no no no so
customers if customers have suitable
premises yes that's only one awarding
body that allows that the other three
awarding bodies that we want to engage
with and offer make a mandatory training
centers only
as far as I was aware two things the
land has been used for horses by the
previous tenant for seven years I have a
statement from them saying the footpath
has never been used in that seven years
that had four to five horses grazing on
it so why are you building Stables if
you haven't got horses so I would like
to have a hobby Farm eventually as part
of my retirement thing and one of the
things I've always looked at I've done a
very little bit of horse riding
previously and I thought that could be
an activity I could get into but I
wanted them to kind of mix it up and
have the flexibility to have a hobby
Farm eventually that's what I want to do
how would you be able to come out of
your
s here and ride these Halls
of all the area locally there is some
limited activities with Bridal waves but
that's not my initial
um activity yeah okay so so so and the
other thing is the mark Heap what are
you proposing to do with that because
that needs to be either not near a water
Course and there are lots of
watercourses if you look at the plans it
is as far away from any Watercourse as
possible it sleeps on the top you still
have to dispose of it yes so my friend
who runs in a question Center said you
you engage with a local company you get
a waste Transfer notice and it has to be
disposed of properly
absolutely
concrete it's concrete slab with three
walls on it typical found in equestrian
centers so we can't live while you're
doing all your hard work will this be
just standing idle I've got no vision of
putting horses on there immediately if
we if we could get this over the line my
main focus will be developing the north
of the site and I'll come back to the
site so it's a dream and a wish yes in
the future yes it's a hobby for SMS
thank you a dream and a wish right
um oh um yeah that's it thank you very
much you've been very helpful very
explanatory
um so thank you for that
uh we now moved
oh I beg your passing Council Stringer
sorry just a couple of things
I just want to clarify a dream and a
wish the plans state
we're being asked for what we're being
asked for aren't we
yeah so so whether someone is intending
to do it or not we're being asked to
Grant permission for what is in the
plans I just want to clarify about the
legal status of footpath 27. according
to the definitive map that is a footpath
so whether someone has blocked it or not
is frankly irrelevant
because that's a separate Enforcement
issue legally there is a footpath that
runs right through the center of the
site in between I believe where the tele
Handler is stored and where it's going
to be used
so what what Provisions are put in to
mitigate those using the football
yeah just before you do um just can I
just ask the legal and between yourself
and myself I would have thought you have
to have an official diversion then could
in help us on that yeah
I think if the point was being made it's
not been used much it's still if it's on
the definitive map it's on the map
leave now
that's the Stringer then on that well it
was more for a question from the officer
because
I just wanted to tell that or try and
illuminate the committee that it talk of
it has been blocked it's totally
irrelevant there is on the definitive
map a footpath that runs here so I was
just asking because we were being told
about how safe it would be to operate
the training on site how the the
applicants will be moved around exactly
but I'm more interested in what how do
we mitigate those that are using the
footpath that could do that quite
legally
with a telehandler moving et cetera Etc
I think the officer might be able to
give us some help here
in fact yes I have got that
so the blue line which I don't know if
it's that clear it's this one that runs
sort of along the whole way through the
site that is the public right way
um rightfully so as you say in terms of
the enforcement of whether it's blocked
or not that is irrelevant to the
planning application and it should
remain free from obstruction obviously
public rights way are um a County
Council matter they have I've been
having quite a few conversations with
them um directly anyway but there is and
it was more for context the public
right-of-way is blocked further up here
at present there is also a gate that is
around here
um which is part of the um the
application but in terms of the actual
making it I suppose free from
obstruction if whatever reason this can
be I mean it technically can be walked
on as you say it's it's a legal footpath
um it is to be
free from obstruction throughout the
whole of the site so yes it does
basically the telehandler tower is
around here
and then you've got obviously it does go
over some um some hard-standing areas it
will have to remain free from
obstruction one of the conditions that
we've put in the table paper does
require
um details of any kind of fencing means
of enclosure whatever so we basically
can confirm with public rights way that
they're happy with the proposal they at
present have no objection to it though
um obviously in terms of you know public
rights away run everywhere all around
the district through agricultural Fields
through you know
cows and everything
um
running around some of them
um so it's just a case but it just has
to remain free from obstruction as I say
in terms of the actual Red Line boundary
it will remain free from obstruction
um it is immaterial to this application
that it is blocked further up but it is
more for context to let you know that it
has been blocked further up
we're really going on quite a lot of
questions can this be your last one
please councilor melon yeah just
clarified about the Buns because I can't
really see much about abundant in the
Landscaping
um
right so the Bund is actually shown on
this Landscaping plan uh Mouse so it's
along here
that is the earth Bond and in terms of
whether it's included within the
development description
um which I think
um Council Guthrie you kind of mentioned
earlier
um it is part of the the Landscaping
works so it is it's part of the plans
it's been assessed by the Landscaping
team by Environmental Health in terms of
noise impacts as well
the lessons are over this way here so if
I interesting right yeah that's okay
thank you yeah okay what I want to know
councilman you had your question um
linked with mine are you happy with the
response that you can make a decision on
what you've heard yeah sorry thank you
it's the the labeling was very much
thank you right excellent right thank
you very much Mr Carr Mr Carl thank you
very much you were very helpful very
informative and obviously clearly a lot
of work done thank you and now we come
to the ward member please thank you very
much
thank you madam chairman and good
morning members I'm speaking on behalf
of not many myself but my fellow Ward
councilor councilor Passmore
proposal included including its previous
Incarnation which was application
2100487
refused and officer delegated authority
has been hanging over the small number
of residents who live in Pittsford since
late in 2019 my first involvement was in
March 2020 literally days before the
first covid lockdown and I was invited
to a meeting with concerned residents
who live in the beautifully converted
farm buildings adjacent to the grade two
listed pootsford farmhouse
their concerns were regarding how the
supposed commercial operation would
impact their daily immunity and quality
of life
over the intervening 30-month period
what has become equally apparent to me
is the strength of feeling in The Wider
Community against this proposal
Cardinal Parish Council oppose it need a
market Town Council who treasure the
River gipping Walk
both the then and Beyond its about town
boundaries oppose it
The Stone Market Ramblers expressed
their objections
Pacific preservation Society have an
interest in this matter as a council t
submitted a detailed two-page letter in
which they're highly qualified planning
officer has clearly set out all their
concerns let me just take a few quotes
about
the letter expresses concerns about the
impact on this special landscape
describes it as a Serene remote and
detached part of the countryside highly
sensitive to further degradation
they feel that the industrial use will
be highly visible within the gipping
Valley Landscape
they say it's introducing an alien and
highly inappropriate feature into this
attractive area
they stress it will entirely change the
appearance of the site to the detriment
of The Wider area
the left then goes on to express
concerns about the impact on the grade 2
listed 16th century Farmhouse of
introducing a distinctly industrial land
use to the original rural setting
it concludes that these proposals are
inappropriate on this sensitive site
it's a fact that the concerns are to the
much wider Civic Community that's
enabled Tim and myself under our calling
policy to call this application in for
determination
so that's concentrating on visual
aspects but the report says that it
concludes after 15 years
Landscaping would still leave some
adverse visual impact on the immediate
proximity
so they roll on the year 2027 15 years
is all that can be said
also what about the noise impact trees
and bushes and burns will never truly
mitigate the noise impact of
construction vehicles and Equipment
being used
the report also mentions the Gallow Hill
Quarry gravel and sand workings across
the narrow River to the southwest of the
site
so another local industrial site you
might think but not not mentioned in the
report but what I'm told by local
residents is that tarmac ceased
extraction from that site in December 21
they are now in the process of creating
a large Nature Reserve there
this welcome news
technique conjunction with the
Improvement Works being undertaken by
the river being trust should bring an
increasing number of visitors to the
area Walkers and hikers nature lovers
bird watchers Etc
giving Trust is working hard to
publicize and Market the beautiful
long-distance Riverside path from
Ipswich to Stow Market
all these marvelous ongoing improvements
feel in stark contrast to the
detrimental proposals in this
application
and residents very concerned about the
access to the site of the A14 a140
interchange roundabout
now I know the highways requesting
significant improvements but I agree
residents it still will remain a tight
sharp left-hand turn which will be
hidden until literally the last few
seconds by anyone coming around the
roundabout from the west or the North
and speaking from personal experience
now I've never relished exercising that
immediate term when visiting Pips
forward from the east of the A14 even
though I've been forewarned and
forearmed about it by the residents
and I believe the 2018 crash that was
referred to was quite a serious one and
the road was closed for some while
it's always effective issues you have
seen the only thing that members can
give any positive waiting to in their
deliberations is some economic benefits
arising if construction training
services realize their aspirations for
this site which is to create a
construction and agricultural training
facility and create a few additional
jobs
upskill in the community is quite
clearly a good thing
but at present I believe they send their
trainer out to a client's site otherwise
a journey of one person as opposed to
getting all their trainees doing to take
multiple Journeys to this site
and respect you've all taken notes of
the applicants use the word agricultural
training if I look at the CTS website
under the tab training course it shows
four headings construction
waste and recycling demolition utilities
and I don't see a mention there of
agricultural
so to conclude the planning officers
made their judgment on the waiting to be
given to the solitary economic benefit
Pro against the waiting to be given to
the various cons highlighted by the
objectives the parish council and by
myself earlier in my speech
taking on balance the officer favors
approval but now it's up to you members
present on the committee to debate all
you've heard today and to make your own
subjective assessment of this planning
application
in doing that the local neighbors the
Cardinal parish and leader Market town
councils and the residents they
represent and indeed the much wider
Community including bodies such as The
Stone Market Ramblers the Civic
preservation Society will help and trust
to balance all these planning aspects
set before you today that you will
collectively refuse this application
thank you madam chairman for your time
thank you very much indeed does anyone
have any questions for the ward member
no I think you covered everything very
fully there thank you very much indeed
right
um well thank you for that and we now
move on to the debate who councilor
Caston
oh yes of course we I did ask about that
a few minutes ago thank you yes crash
map please yes so just to confirm um it
was an incident in April 2018 which was
a serious incident
um and involved two vehicles with one
casualty
that's all the information I have
okay
um you'll have to make your judgment on
that counselor um with knowledge that
you have of the incident yourself
perhaps
the exactly the same information yeah
how much does it okay right so who wants
to start the debate off please counselor
Muller thank you very much chair uh
We've listened to the very interesting
argument Fallen against this uh
particular application I must admit from
an economic development point of view
and growth there are shortages in these
particular traits of Agriculture and
construction it's really important that
we get some people qualified in those as
soon as possible but I think we also
have to consider What the residents have
said and also the war members that they
are actually totally opposed this
application and obviously has been
refused before so at the moment I must
admit you I'm actually sitting on the
fence on this particular one but I do
have some concerns about it and I'll be
interested to hear what other members
have to say thank you cheers thank you
for that councilor Norris and then
councilor Caston thank you
uh thank you chair
I know this site very well I regularly
passed by it when I'm traveling from
Needham Market to the i-14 I fully
support the objections to this
application by the condom Parish Council
need a market Town Council the river
give entrust to the numerous public
objections that have been submitted soft
preservation Society have also objected
and mentioned a number of concerns in
their comments at the top of page 62.
this application is very similar to the
previous application submitted on this
site doesn't very little if anything to
address the primary reasons for the
previous refusal I.E the site is
situated in an environmentally sensitive
area of the gipping Valley and the
proposed development would create
potentially serious impacts on landscape
as the site Falls within the gipping
valley special landscape area
on local amenity and they're joining an
environment including an inevitable
increase in immunity noise disturbance
and the impact on designated Heritage
Assets in the vicinity
there is a lack of any evidence to
justify the principle of such
development of the manner proposed in
this location there are more suitable
sites within mid-suffolk for what is
proposed which is essentially Industrial
Development in a Countryside setting
the long-born industrial estate at
Needham Market has recently had a
further extension and there is of course
the Gateway 14 development
the proposed access close to a
roundabout on a very busy Junction of
the A14 and the a140 is inappropriate
and undesirable
therefore I cannot support this
re-application for such proposed
development which would be fundamentally
in an unsuitable and inappropriate
location thank you
thank you for that councilor councilor
Council you are next
I'm chairman
um
I'm a little bit worried that the the
impact of this
is um being exaggerated a bit so um we
have a forklift of modern forklifts are
a little bit more noisy than a vacuum
cleaner the um they get a bit noisier
when you're using Hydraulics and things
like that but you're not driving faster
they're crawling along the ground
there's some there's a very much a need
for this kind of activity and um it has
to be done somewhere where the land
value is suitable for doing this for
doing this kind of work you can't do it
on Industrial Estates and places like
that you you pay too much to rent or or
buy the land the um
the um
the the the student needs to be trained
in the most suitable Place possible and
I think that um a site with
um classrooms and this staging and
everything is going to be the safest
best place for them to get that training
the um the business has um
put the the business has a Bund
um to reduce noise it has it's moved
aspects of the business around to reduce
noise it's some I to be honest I I think
there'll be very little impact from this
it's um
the um yeah the um
I think having a bus going from Needham
as well satisfies a lot of the worries
about people and driving and the more
you know more car Journeys going through
there it's um
it's off-grid there's some not going to
be the heating is
um acceptable because what you've got to
remember is the people being trained are
going to be wearing overalls and um
still take out boots so they don't need
a really warm office style environment
for me I can't
I I think people will find this hasn't
got the impact
that they think it has I can understand
why people are worried about it and but
I think it I think it's necessary we've
got a lot of people need to be trained
they need to be
trained in a safe environment so at the
moment I would be um looking to approve
this application but I'll listen to the
other members
Council of War boys and then councilor
Stringer
myself in an agreement with the previous
speaker uh
I find it difficult to go and see
um recommendations of the office of page
75
it very clearly states a planning in
exercising a planning judgment it is
considered the landscape harm is
outweighed by the merits of The Proposal
and our own Heritage officer also says
um
a very low
degree of harm less than significant
harm to pitch forward there will be some
impact
on the dwellings without fail and this
is a growing and interesting developing
environmental space
um
there is a travel plan which will
mitigate sort of travel it's in terms of
sustainability from an energy point of
view a great deal of thought has been
put into into that it's great for
agricultural language is is more
suitable for grazing it's of limited use
so I can be corrected on that but
that's my thoughts
um the context of it it's adjacent to
the A14 it's off around about the access
is going to be improved which will
improve safety for all users of that
road
um
the the travel plan includes traveling
from Needham market so there'll be one
Journey a day so there won't be that
much additional use
I would like to see the public
right-of-way some that re the protection
for that really enhanced them and it's
outside this meeting but I think this
gate should be looked at and where it
can be removed or not
um
but and again
Council stringers
raised the
issue of the teleport to being used
across the right of way so that perhaps
needs to be looked at carefully
um
I'll practice my concerns because I I
feel the the
the it has been looked at in quite
detail and the economic impact we are
got a
skills crisis we're talking about
building skills centers across
the district for various reasons
construction trades there's a huge
shortage
um
the flood risk and drainage which was
what raises a concern this is on the
highest part of the site
um
and there's a soft Landscaping I I do
think Council Castle as that there will
be some impact but it will be very
love and the the economic benefits
I agree with what the officer says will
that wait
very much indeed Council singer I think
human
yeah thank you chair uh I don't quite
know where my thoughts are at the moment
but purely because
I I'm slightly confused with what I'm
being told and what's written in the
document and my training says Focus
what's written on the document
so when I focused what's written on the
document
it doesn't tell me that that application
is not for one telehandler
where everyone arrives by minibus that's
not what it is in the title that's not
what it says in the rest of the
documentation
it's 30 car parking spaces
so if they're all going to come in by
minibus why are there 30 car parking
spaces
the other bit that I I can I can see how
some of the harm is mitigated I get that
and we desperately need to train people
there are other courses available in
emoji
we are also talking about one particular
it's not forklift is a telehandler I
believe we've been told we're having not
a forklift
telehandle
that is just one course
about with a myriad of other
Machinery that could be operated on the
site it doesn't say for telehandling use
only in the application
could it also be used for tractors
for crushers
for all sorts of other training courses
that are available skid steer loaders
ride on rollers could it be used for
that with the approval of this title I I
I'm being told one thing that could be
mitigated
because there is identified harm but the
amount of training courses here is for
one piece of equipment when there are
loads of other pieces of equipment that
also need to be trained for so can we
just ask yes please the the planning
office is this just for Italian can you
handle one single telehandle yeah or
will there be
there be um all of the bits Machinery
that need to be used on site that's not
just going to be a telehandler
um there are a number of courses that
are listed within the report
um
I'm not sure what page it's on
um under section two in terms of The
Proposal it talks about the
classroom-based stuff the construction
and practical training so construction
plant and Access Equipment obviously
that's not just going to be a tele
Handler
uh yes I'm not sure you're on page 65 in
the main bundle
um but I think in terms of the you know
it says all-terrain vehicles
um they really there are some conditions
proposed including site management plan
um to be submitted
um travel plan to be submitted as well
which would then secure shuttle bus
obviously there will be the need for
people to travel by car that is why
there's parking
um
thus
I don't know if you if you want some
specific
vehicles that are going to be used plant
construction that sort of thing then it
might be worth directing that to the
applicant
I mean just to add to the debate
counselor I mean I'm looking through the
pages as as we all are and I just
noticed on page 66 crushed concrete area
for equestrian use I'm not sure what the
question would use crushed concrete but
never mind
um but the crushed concrete so does that
mean The Crushers will be on site
you know the crushed concrete area for
the question bit is where the Stables
are to be it's just when it's being laid
laid on it's not actually in use
yeah but um councilor Stringer I stopped
you mid flow because I thought it was
appropriate that we had the that's
incredibly helpful so
like I said we've been told there is
only going to be one piece of equipment
that's going to be used for training
what I can't see that lock down in
either condition or title so for
instance if I look at particular
training courses would this this
approval would allow something like an
excavator to be used to be trained on
um
you know Road rollers that kind of thing
that that's the bit I'm trying to work
because if it was going to be if we're
going to we've identified harm and the
mitigation for the harm is the amount of
skills it can impart to people therefore
if you're going to
lose this area and create the harm it
needs to deliver the vast amount of
skills as many skills as possible but
then of course what you're then doing is
allowing the ramping up of the harm so
what I'm asking is if it is only a
telehandler and it's one telehandler
where is that in the application and
where is that controlled in the
condition
yeah if I I yes I may I mean I'm sure
Jasmine could say this equally well I
mean it I'm sure won't surprise anyone
in this any member to be reminded if you
grant permission for change of use of
passive land to a construction
agricultural training facility Etc that
means what it says
and it's only if the conditions or 106
obligation restricts the nature of the
Machinery that that would and Jasmine
has just taken you quickly through the
conditions that are on page 79 so that
yes if the applicant tells you they have
a specific intention that's fair enough
but that's not they're not limited to
that by the permission unless unless it
says so in conditions
thank you cancer
points to make um at the moment no no I
don't but I I think it you get why I'm
slightly confused
councilor Mellon you were going to speak
thank you very much
yeah thank you chair
um yeah I mean I find like some of my
colleagues on the on the committee that
I'm on the fence on this one there's
there's reasons kind of either way
um when I sort of made a kind of list of
the pros clearly this is agricultural
land at the moment therefore a farmer
could underpermitted development rights
probably put up an agricultural building
if he required it for his business and
what we have in this application is an
agricultural looking building albeit
it's going to be a training center but
it could be you know a chicken barn or
something
instead so that potentially could happen
anyway
clearly there is um
the need for training I mean I have a
telehander license I've done that
training a few times I've always done it
on site on a farm rather than go
elsewhere but other other trainings are
often delivered you know in a training
center agricultural college or something
like that
um so there is that need for training
um on the sort of negative side
um there is a real concern in my mind
about the access off that roundabout and
the extra traffic that this will
generate and clearly they you know the
applicants have cited this here because
it has good access to the the A14 the
a140 people are mostly going to be
arriving by car I would assume
um you know it'd be great if the minibus
shuttle minibus to Dunedin Market
station came along but I should think
the majority of people are still going
to be coming by car so that does add to
that kind of concern about that
roundabout
I still have a question mark in my mind
over really whether this facility could
be could be powered and heated by PV
panels I suspect that generator is going
to be there for quite a long time so I
still find myself sort of on the fence
on this one I can see there's pluses and
minuses and I'm still waiting to hear
what others have to say thank you
anyone else wish to speak councilor
Gould
a fence sitter I'm afraid
and I I listened very carefully to all
the all the presentations not least
cancer whiteheads
um and when he drew his remarks to a
conclusion about the balance
of harm to to benefit here and that's
the crutch of this matter I don't think
I haven't heard anyone
um again saved the need for this
training uh to to meet the skills
shortage through the provision of
training uh I have I I feel confident
that there are alternative sites that
could be used for this but they are not
before us so we have to judge what is
um
the uh listen very carefully to
councilor Customs
analysis and I think he's he's
um he's writing what he says and and uh
that would lead me towards uh uh
approval
but there are concerns and I suppose the
three particular things that are in my
mind here are are one about the the
access
um problems with the access the other is
okay the right-of-way can be needs to be
kept clear for the potential conflict
between people using that footpath and
the training operation uh
excuse me with some anxiety I I have to
say and the the other thing
um
is about the we've concentrated on the
tele Handler but what other equipment is
included within the description that
listen to prayers reminded us if we
agree that that is what we agreeing for
those purposes but Does it include
things like
chainsaws uh training and and the like
which are are incredibly noisy uh and I
can see that noise and visits that noise
moving downhill uh over the band and uh
in into in into the properties so those
um a kind of
the need the need to provide these
skills and this training I think is is
kind of a Paramount consideration but I
have those concerns that kind of keeps
me on the fence just at the moment
since thank you
thank you well I'm the only one who
hasn't spoken and I know councilor
Muller wants to come back so I think as
we're having a debate I
um and I've been listening to you all
and making notes in one thing and
another
um and
we've got to be careful with highways
highways have said it's safe well it's
safe allegedly for the roundabout it's
safe allegedly for the entrance but I
have concerns of the seven other
households that use this area and people
coming and going and whatever whether
it's 30 cars coming or robust or
whatever they will still be using it so
from a highways point of view I have
concerns that area and we know full well
when highways have said it's safe then
we're on a bit of a Sticky Wicket if we
want to say no but I think immunity
might come into it I don't know if
members are so minded I worry about
um
uh much of what councilor
um Whitehead has said and I know all the
report is telling us that the noise can
be mitigated and so on and I am much
appreciate the gentleman who've come
forward and worked hard to get to where
they are but I do think there must be
other areas and before as chairman I'm
entitled to have a briefing beforehand
and I put loads of questions to make
sure that the officer has got everything
she can possibly tell us about it and
one of the things I did say well you
know what about otley college well
lockley College doesn't do it so there
is a lack of of training in the area so
I did make inquiries about that
um
I can't sit on the fence much myself but
but I'm stuck because
I've always banged on about we're in a
rural community and we need rural people
to work we can't have the top jobs for
everybody but we can have good quality
jobs training and apprenticeships and I
listen to people who are farmers that
you may or may not know on our committee
and they've done their training on site
with a telehandler but there is a lot of
other equipment and I mean I'm lucky I
live in the countryside but the farm
locally has a lot of equipment and I
often hear it well I accept that because
that's a farm and it's a working farm
this is in a quiet area
um I I'm worried that we're
industrializing
agricultural land when it could still be
used for grazing be it sheep or pigs or
whatever and I just worry we've got all
these other places that are clamoring
for business wanting them to use their
sights
I just worry that we've got other sites
that haven't fully been investigated but
again that's not before us this is
what's before us and do we want to
vote this through
I'm sticking but I know Council Muller
was going to have another go at
something but somebody's got to come up
with some idea or other shortly because
we've pondered over this greatly so can
we have councilor Muller
thank you chair uh well the applicant
has already said that he spent several
years trying to find other locations for
this and I said I totally accept What
the residents and the parish character I
have to say and also also the war member
but you you raise the point again there
chair we have a drastic shortage of
skills in these particular areas and I
personally I think we need to to look at
that and we do need these skills we need
these these people trained so that we
can grow the economy Etc and you're
right we can only consider what is
before us I do accept the point about
the access to the site but as you say
highways have said it's acceptable
um so considering what my colleague came
to the castle and uh councilor War boys
has said
overall I would if the councilor casting
was to recommend approval then I would
second that
um
yeah
I'm I'm happy to propose but what I'd
like to
um talk about is a condition because um
cancer string has made a very good point
that we could
actually find ourselves with steel
tracked excavators tracking across the
site we it could it could be a lot
noisier it doesn't sound like that's
what the applicant wants to do at all so
I don't think that would bother the
applicant if we made some form of
condition to safeguard against that but
I don't know if that's possible
I've been working on various uh
conditions suggested additional
conditions based on a variety of things
members have said so it doesn't
specifically cover that but a whole
range of things if I might carry on with
that so I've suggested a restriction on
the height of container stacking because
unconscious that was mentioned
um some further information on
horsemanure storage and removal again
that was mentioned by members some fuel
storage details would suggest hours of
operation again so that we've got that
controlled specifically so you'll you
know we can agree the hours and know
that that's restricted that we install
the Advanced Landscaping essentially
first that's one of the first things
that happens on site so again appreciate
Landscaping takes it's time to come in
if we can get it in first that you know
builds as much buffer period as we can
that we make sure we get the provision
of the PV panels and then perhaps
critically to the discussion that's just
come up is that I would suggest details
to be agreed for equipment use numbers
and Machinery including interaction with
the public right-of-way so perhaps an
agreed position where it crosses how
it's crossed that it will cross in
forward gear that they'll be stopping
and give away all that kind of signage
to make sure we've got absolute control
over that does that cover the issues
that have come up or is there anything
else I can
so um yeah we've got a condition there
talking about the number of vehicles but
we don't actually have a number or with
what's acceptable how would we um
decide on that because um
yes so just as a kind of
I suppose going back to the kind of
amenity concerns that have been raised
and the two conditions that we've kind
of noted within the recommendation
already include site management plan and
independent noise assessment to be
carried out prior to first use obviously
there was a noise assessment conducted
as part of this application
so in terms of what they have assessed
it will be because that is what is
proposed to be operating on site
obviously if there are a number of
additional vehicles that were not
assessed by that noise assessment then
that is is not gonna
um I suppose be acceptable to
environmental health because an
independent noise assessment has been
required by them per the the
recommendation to be carried out prior
to first use so obviously if a million
you know different Vehicles turn up on
site
um then that's that's clearly going to
surpass the noise that had been assessed
and it's not going to be acceptable and
so there are kind of different
conditions that cover different aspects
of it
um but in terms of we can obviously
include as gem has kind of said certain
details within some of the conditions
already but there are a multitude of
different conditions kind of catching on
to different elements of concern I think
we could also relate the number and type
of Machinery back to the noise
assessment so that it's got to comply
with the noise assessment and if it
doesn't for any reason to request the
updated noise assessment so they could
adjust the numbers and types but it
would have to that overall level I think
we could word something to that effect
yeah I'm I'm happy that that covers it
um the time restriction
what would that look like would would
what days and
would that just cover operating machines
it wouldn't cover the running of the
business
I think we could we could certainly have
a condition that covers it all um so
well I think it really kind of did Cover
the Machinery side of things
machinery and the hours that are
actually you could have it as part of
kind of one condition
um which again would be assessed in
regard to that noise assessment
environmental health
um
by us as well
and the other thing that I was
interested in is Council Mellon talked
about the
um
reversing
signal of those machines and I think um
for me that site would have to be um
white noise
or something better
and and definitely no explain so the
public knows what a white noise is so um
as far as I understand it's the
difference between a audible beep when
the vehicle's reversing and a
when the television is not
tuned in you get that
I know that's not very technical
um but it's um it's a lot less
disruptive to people
to be honest I think the
whatever the industry
um designates as the appropriate thing
would be suitable for that I don't like
the idea of not having any reversing
signals at all because if somebody
leaves the vehicle in reverse
and they don't realize it's it's quite
good like that but I think for me the
only thing that a condition for us would
cover is not having the um the
the
um audible beep reversing signals
um having some other form so I think
previously with condition s so no
reversing sensors to be used that sounds
like the White Noise available if needed
yeah perfect
um yeah and um the only other thing I
wanted to talk about is the footpath do
we need some form of scheme to make sure
that's as safe as it can possibly be
um yes so one of the conditions that's
proposed as part of the table papers I
think it was
um does mention about a scheme of kind
of boundary treatments and how that's
going to be free from obstruction number
one
certainly add to that condition to kind
of talk about how it's going to be I
suppose safe as well
um to ensure that obviously there is
some some mitigation and measures in
place to ensure that yeah
I'm happy that that would be um done by
officers Say Yeah I'm
I yeah I'm proposing it with the
conditions we just talked about which I
think
with that in mind would members like to
speak to the motion then please um I
think councilor Mellon had his hand up
first and then councilor Stringer if
that's all right with you councilman
yeah sorry it was just on the um
conditions because
um our environmental health people have
come up with some proposed conditions on
page 141 I'm not sure we've captured all
of those I think there's six or seven
which are again about the noise and that
sort of thing
it does say no more than six items of
plant at any one time which
um seems slightly different to what the
Perkins proposed but can I just clarify
that whether those are in they're in the
conditions we're proposing yes yes so
they are actually mentioned as part of
falling within the condition to do with
the site management plan and so as I say
that that condition will be expanded and
we can include all the kind of elements
that have been discussed including what
has been proposed by environmental
health
yeah yeah thank you chair uh I I want to
speak against the proposal I think now
now that I've I think I fully understand
what we're being asked to agree uh a
number of serious reservations despite
what the highways
crew have said
own personal experience and witnessing
almost daily near misses on that
Junction I think any intensification in
that area should be resisted at all cost
despite the fact there could be quote
improvements by widening it but that but
you're not actually going to improve
that left hand turn where you almost
double back on yourself
that's not that's not brilliant
I have concerns that you've you were
allowing we applaud the intention to be
off-grid but if by off-grid we have a
decade of diesel diesel generators
that's not brilliant so there's an
element of and equally I'm not quite
sure how clodusters work on off in
off-grid locations
because you can't afford to have an
outage if you've got a clan Chester
so there is an element immediately there
that starts ringing alarm Bells we've
got this conflict with the footpath
we've got conflict with what is quite
despite the A14 rattling past it it's a
it's quite a very rural uh
dispersed area that's relatively
tranquil I'd have thought in a river
valley uh
I can't see that the district council's
economic development department has done
a sequential test and asked where this
could be cited I can think of three
places in my own Ward alone where this
could be cited without any problem at
all
my theory is what what what's going to
be approved that it will not be limited
to one type of vehicle there will be
lots of different vehicles in and out of
there doing different training why
wouldn't you want it to be successful if
you're going to sacrifice land for
Industry and Training it needs to be
able to be rev to the Max and you can't
rev this site to the max because of how
sensitive it is therefore in my mind we
are in the wrong place
we are trying to insert something into
where it will be too difficult uh so for
me I I
wouldn't support this in its current
form because I believe we want it to be
successful but it is successful you'll
be pushing at the bounds of what is
sustainable and you'll just be setting
up a load of complaints in the future
thank you chair
may we go to the vote please unless you
uh could I just check that members are
okay with all the conditions as part of
this proposal or do you need Gemma to go
through them again before we vote
I just um I believe that the generator's
not been kept on the site for Beyond a
year is already conditioned
in there
um
did I not see that in the paper uh
you've yeah well you've kind of confused
two conditions so the container storage
um not container storage rather the
temporary cabins they're the things that
are on there for for only year and the
diesel generator that is
considered to be temporary but we
haven't got a condition on that and what
we have proposed is a condition for
States for sustainability measures so
that could be incorporated into that
scheme for us to assess
um how you know it's how successful it's
going to be in terms of battery storage
with PV panels
um I think Gemma said that there was a
condition specifically requiring the PV
panels as well yeah so I think we'll
also the implementation of the PV panels
at the earliest opportunity again I
would be hesitant against conditioning
specifically against the diesel
generator
because you're getting into chattels and
doesn't need permission and how do we
restrict it and if it's gone off and on
again where the breach it becomes a
problematic thing so I think we can
secure the early implementation of the
PV panels and as Jasmine said we've got
a condition to drive the sustainability
benefits home that should be a pence
movement towards being rid of the diesel
generator but not something I'd say we
could specifically prevent by itself
right okay yeah my second is happy
so just to confirm everyone is okay with
what we're voting on so
chair members that vote is now in
progress
councilor War boys is your vote going
through or would you like me to take it
verbally
it's easily done that's fine
a favor okay okay so chair that makes
five votes four and three against so
that has been approved
indeed we need to have um a 10 minute
break now for members um thank you very
much and thank you to everybody for
attending thank you
welcome back and thank you very much
indeed
um we now move on to um the first case
that we had DC 2204313
unit one giving Way Stone Market
and I will now invite the case officer
Amelia Powell who's presenting this for
the first time to us for the committee
so we look forward to that thank you
Amelia off you go
thank you chair
um
so I'm presenting a full planning
application that seeks the change of use
of a premises from retail to hot food
takeaway the installation of a new shop
front and external plants
and this is in Stone Market in the St
Peters Ward
just to note that this presentation is
an introduction and additional
illustration of some of the points
within the published committee report it
does not supplement the committee report
and it acts merely as a springboard for
debate
all applications must be assessed on
their own individual planning merits
after having had regard to all material
planning considerations
so here's the site in a wider Geographic
context a stone Market is on the western
side of the A14 and southeast of berry
and Northwest of Ipswich
um and more of a local context the site
is located in the center of Stone Market
West of The Stone Market railway station
and on the western side of gippingway
and immediate context
um surrounding and within close
proximity to the site there are several
existing pubs and bars including the
Queen's heads the Stag Tavern and carbon
nightclub
the site itself is just here and Berry
Street is essentially the center of the
Town Center
the site is immediately next door to
Pure gym with a public car park to the
north and south of the site with a total
of 103 parking spaces
Berry Street is a primary Street within
Stone Market town center and is south of
the site and the excise site is
accessible from gippingway
the unit was originally occupied by Aldi
and more recently poundland and
following a sustained period of vacancy
the unit was subdivided in 2020 so one
half approximately is the pure gym which
is open 24 7 and the other half is
currently vacant
uh there are Residential Properties uh
just on the right there
um and going on from that to the wards
the north there is an additional car
park out of that picture
there is a existing restaurant
um
uh Turkish and Mediterranean restaurant
Ella
um and the nearest residential dwelling
is 26.6 meters north of the site
just there showing the restaurant and
the closest house from the site
and looking along Union Street at the
end here is the car park that I was
talking about before and the other car
parked to the north of the site and
gippingway is runs just along here
so the building was last occupied by
poundland as a retail unit under class
E's classification
and planning permission here is for the
internal and minor external works
and the remainder of the building will
remain Class E use and will be subject
to a planning application for a new shop
front if permission is granted on this
application
the total proposed ground floor space is
93 square meters
constraints around the site so it does
lie within The Stone Market Conservation
Area and there are several grade two
listed buildings
um to the west south and east and a
grade two stylisted building uh
Southeast which is the Saint Peter and
Mary's Church
so the site is within as I said The
Stone Market town center
and The Stone Market area action plan
states that for the purposes of
development within the defined Town
Center any retail Frontage that is not
on the primary shopping Frontage will be
considered as being within a secondary
shop in Frontage so the site does lie on
a secondary Street and so it is
considered acceptable in accordance with
the stowmarket area action plan
um for there to be a hot food takeaway
establishment
um so the proposed internal and external
alterations are modest in scale the
principle and external elevation will be
a replacement of the existing servicing
doors with a new shop front to provide
customer and staff entrance as secondary
access will be on the side elevation
which is the north elevation on there
but the main entrance will be on the
west uh essentially the principal
elevation which fronts the public car
park
internal alterations include the
creation of a customer Reception Area
Sales counter and to the rear a new
kitchen which would include preparation
and dispatch areas baking ovens dry and
cold storage areas wash-up area control
Hub and staff toilet
um yeah just showing the different areas
of the floor plan
the proposed shop front
is using what's currently already there
which is a wall and access door it's a
simple design an aluminum frame and
glazed door
it was previously not glazed with
Windows the same size as it was shelving
and in accordance with the good design
guide there's a prefer not to have
glazing with where there's shelving
and this is the side North elevation
which shows the side staff entrance and
fire exit and the extract grills and
flus and the toilet extract and
condensers
um
since this was put in which is shown in
the committee report additional details
have been submitted which I'll go
through later but the bin storage will
be on the side elevation but on the
North away from the main entrance and
since the committee report a litter
management plan has also been submitted
which I will discuss later but is in the
table papers
so looking at the site from the car park
adjacent to the principal elevation
shows the pure gym to right there which
is open 24 7 and the current vacant
building where the Papa John's hot food
establishment will be
and looking from the north in the back
there is the grade two stylisted church
and as you can see the car park is ever
considered size
um from standing in front of the site
this is the back of Berry Street
um where there are grade two listed
buildings
um you can get into Berry Street through
here and there's another entrance down
here which I'll show later and here is
the Turkish restaurant
um as I mentioned before existing links
which are pedestrian access only come
from very steep Berry Street and Station
Road bus
from standing in front of the existing
gym which is the other half of
the building this shows the car park and
at the end just here is an entrance to
Berry Street
[Applause]
so it's proposed that the use will
operate between the hours of 11 till
midnight Sunday to Wednesday and 11 A.M
until 2 A.M Thursday to Saturday
um the takeaway establishment will
provide jobs to 15 to 20 employees with
there being six to seven members of
Staff in the store at any given point as
well as approximately four delivery
drivers
um
the Papa John's
um have said that they will provide two
to four parking permits for delivery
drivers to utilize the adjacent public
car park
um and it is noted that there is not any
specific on-site parking but there's
obviously three car parks within close
proximity to the site
um and I will come on to the cycle
storage later
um so the additional information that's
been submitted since the committee
report there is fencing around the bins
and the proposal will utilize the
existing area adjacent to the building
on the side elevation as well as a
loading Bay that's already there
um and the bins will accommodate to 1
100 liter bins
um and one will be for General waste and
one for cardboard recycling and the bins
will be emptied on a weekly basis
um to prevent pests Refuge bins will be
lockable wheelie bins and the applicant
has a standard contact contract with
Pest Control agency to control and
manage the presence of them and around
the premises
um and since the uh committee report the
cycle storage has also been submitted so
there's two bike racks
um on just the principal elevation where
that is there just to note there is a
typo in the tabled papers
um two racks equates to four cycle
spaces which is in accordance with
Suffolk parking guidance
so the site has been vacant since its
former use of poundland and prior to
that Aldi and the proposal will bring
back the use of a vacant floor space
into economic use in a town center this
will therefore support the Vitality of
Stone Market Town Center as well as
providing jobs for local people the
takeaway established would also be
beneficial to still markets nightlife
economy with the site being accessible
from local pubs and the nightclub carbon
located near stowmarket railway station
although there are other fast food
restaurants in stowmarket none are in
direct proximity to where this proposed
Papa John's restaurant would be the
proposal would enhance natural
surveillance and provide a sense of
security and safety for locals and
locals and visitors therefore enhancing
inclusivity into the area
and the takeaway establishment would
provide supervision of the existing car
park particularly at night
and although there is likely to be
additional activity in the area that may
or may not generate antisocial Behavior
conditions listed in the committee
report have been suggested to minimize
this risk
and it should also be recognized that
this town this site lies within the Town
Center where noise and late night
activity is typical particularly at
weekends
in summary it's not considered that the
proposal would result in any significant
impact on highway safety immunity
Heritage assets the environment or
biodiversity interest to Warrant refusal
therefore recommendation is to Grant
permission
thank you chair any questions thank you
very much um I think I did ask in the
briefing for you to mention about the um
hours that although they're two separate
things they may well need a license uh
for operating food late at night I
didn't recall you mentioning that then
did you mention it and I missed it I'm
sorry
because they are two separate things but
the public need to know that the the
licensing is required
um and and they need to apply for it
yes so because it's open past 11 pm they
would require a license but it's not a
planning matter and can be dealt with
separately no but equally when you see
hours on here for planning and people go
ah yeah um and unfortunately being chair
of Licensing we also sort of tend to
have a nose into these sort of things
um but very well presented thank you
very much I do have two questions and
you're not getting away
um
you said excuse me committee if I may
indulge
um you said the staff toilet will this
be usable by a disabled person
will that be appropriately designed do
you know
um I know that it's all on a ground
floor layout and there are no stairs
within
um this ground floor layout and so it
would be accessible but I'll need to
double check yeah and the other thing is
you say there are no stairs but on the
side of one of the photographs you
showed there were stairs going up to
this to where the staff come in so is
there a ramp there or or did I miss that
again I did look twice at two of the
pictures you put up there
um because
um
might be um
to use stairs do you know if that's a
case
I would need to confirm that with the
agent
yeah I'm just looking at the plans it
looks to me like the WC has got
sufficient space for turning space it's
quite large there it would depend on the
design and layout but I think
yeah it does look like it from from the
plan I mean without measuring but that
does appear to be the case and again
just looking at the access although the
staff access does have the steps we have
obviously got the front door is flat
level access which again presumably you
would be able to get in the building it
might just depend on which access you go
and unlocking and protocols but yes
absolutely well by anybody's
sorry um so does anybody else
okay I appreciate this isn't probably
crucial to this planning application but
in the um cooking and serving space
plan layout there appears to be
something in the middle of that room
that's not labeled is is that at
actually in that room
or is that
is that something on the roof or
something just to show you where it is
that's the extractor so that's that's
the floor there with nothing
nothing in your way oh yeah okay yeah
fine
stranger thank you thank you chair a
couple of things one is uh local
knowledge is a helpful thing the
immediately to the left of the new door
there is a very horrible little wall and
a radical change in
height I've seen no end of people fall
over that and injure themselves
we're looking and and nobody normally
walks around that area because there's
nothing to attract them there even when
the poundland was there it was nothing
it was just a wall well if we're
attracting people to walking in there
there is quite a horrible
actually the pictures missed it all of
them uh yeah
because it was built to accommodate a
45-foot lorry
no that's not it no no
I don't think there is well it's just
missed it it's there it's underneath
it's there that bit there you can see
where that hot that little wall is that
Wall's not big enough for you to for not
fall over you can fall over it and if
you do fall over you drop down into that
pit where they used to take Lorry
containers into the into the supermarket
that area there is loads of people trip
up on it they
there's no easy safe way to sort of walk
into that area
from the car park and if we're going to
intensify that use that ought to be safe
can we bring that into debate for
example lighting or something yeah
one other thing I noticed normally on
these if we're talking about introducing
hot food takeaway till two in the
morning we normally get a comment from
the police to say that they it's easy to
please at the moment in Stone Market all
of the hot food takeaways in one street
and it makes it very easy to please
whereas what we're now doing is
introducing hot food takeaway into into
a subordinate Street we would normally
have a comment from them to say this is
this is perfectly acceptable or we see
some conflict here so the question is
were the police assaulted the the other
thing is
I certainly get a bit of Correspondence
living really this is the most popular
car park for people that shop in Stone
Market from our end of the world they're
getting increasingly frustrated about
not being able to get a parking space
here now because of all the free permits
given to users of the gym
so there's another loss of parking
spaces here now for permits for the
delivery drivers there's going to be
cars zooming in and out delivering
pizzas to old and Sundry uh so so has
Economic Development commented upon that
loss of more parking spaces for Shoppers
into the town
um so in terms of parking I actually use
the gym next door and uh it's not a free
parking permit you can't stay any longer
um than an hour you don't necessarily
have to pay but I've never had trouble
parking there and have gone at different
times of day because there are three
separate car parks that are all within
close proximity to the site
um hopefully with the cycle racks we'll
be promoting sustainable transport and
with the site being in a town center it
is accessible by public transport as
well
approached I think don't you think
you bring that up in
very well aware when if that they will
have we've been told they'll have to be
a licensing application as well and the
police will be expressly consulted on
that exactly and they can make points on
crime disorder as a licensing objective
and and councilor Stringer will be on
that committee as well should we ever
you're on our licensing committee aren't
you
can we bring that up in debate between
us all councilor councilman
yeah thank you Chet um so just a
question on the the
cast of the string was asking
them clearly the the kind of side
entrance with the stairs goes down into
the lower car park against skipping way
is
clearly obviously there's going to be a
lot of pizza
to their own in-house team or whether
they're going to be using you know Uber
Eats or whoever does this sort of thing
but it are they mainly going to be
coming in from that side entrance and
therefore parking in the lower car park
Which is less busy or are they going to
be coming to the front door to pick up
the pizza you may not know this but it
could be quite critical to the operation
of it
the delivery deliveries would be coming
in through the front door on the main
elevation
Morris are you
thank you uh yes the application is for
a hot food takeaway
on the floor plan on post 26 and
probably easier to see on page 54 slide
six
shown at the left hand then there of the
floor plan is colored yellow is what's
called a customer area with breakfast
bar two breakfast bars with seats so is
this not also effectively a restaurant
so the breakfast bar areas are for
people waiting or delivery delivery
drivers waiting to pick up collections
it's not a restaurant
thank you chair uh Justin it hinges on
what counselors Stringer is referring to
uh in terms of security is there
additional lighting plan to be outside
in the level of lighting in the car I
have walked through it once I think and
the level of lighting isn't terribly
High
um so would there be additional lighting
and I was second one too well so I think
Amelia's just checking if you if you
want to go with the second question then
perhaps
yes I I got some questions really about
sort of delivery I mean the Temptation
for a delivery driver will be to pull in
at the side of the building not into the
car park at all
um
you know just so that what is the
question the question is is
would that be permissible or or is it
sort of
um described as a no waiting no parking
area
decided immediately to the by the low
wall and and
the steps yes
the
um applicant agent has confirmed in the
planning statement and that the delivery
drivers will be using the public car
park
to the front of the site
and your other question regarding the
lighting no further lighting has been
proposed but I assume if planning
permission is granted when they put in
their ad consents application whether
this is illuminated lighting or not that
will be covered then but with there
being the gym already there and
residential houses and a restaurant
already there is sufficient lighting
around that part of the site for
delivery drivers and visitors
well we can debate that can't we
counselor okay so
um have we finished with our questions
at the moment and can we move into
debate
thank you very much for that Amelia and
was there are we short of an answer to
any of the questions or do we get them
all sorry I'll just sort of lost I think
we all got the quest the answers but
whether we like them or not might be a
different thing
um who'd like to kick off with that then
please
councilman
I should have declared I am actually
Vice chair of The Stone Market Town
Council planning committee and we did
discuss this and the Town Council fully
supported this application uh but I do
take on board the comments of of
colleagues that have actually said that
particularly the war that councilor
Stringer sort of mentioned and the
parking but um generally personally I
have got no no objections to this
particular applications here but I'll
listen to what other people might have
to say thank you that councilor carlston
thank you
thank you very much yeah I I think this
improves the area it is starting to look
a bit run down in that area and with the
um I believe that's all vacant
at the moment
um and it I think it will just improve
the area what when I first started
looking at this what worried me
was
um
I don't know if it's licensing or
whether it's planning is but what
worried me is um people leaving carbon
nightclub
turning right towards Union Street and
just climbing up that wall and going
across the um the vegetation whatever
whatever that is
um to cut the corner into it
um it's it's difficult really because
what you're gonna do
um put a pathway there put a larger
fence or anything but um it's almost a
little bit better
than them coming round the cancer side
of stay market and cut him through
to for them to stay on that um road but
I don't know whether that's something
that we need to be thinking about here
because um let's give people the benefit
of the doubt to um use the proper
Pathways yeah shall we just ask Gemma
because I mean I want to to the councils
have brought up the issue of the low War
we might have to suggest as a condition
we put up a fence you know a metal fence
or something I don't know I think there
is a fence where I'm talking about but
it's not it's not a defense that will
defeat a um a 20 year old but that's not
what planning's about you know I mean
you know we don't want that
that safe as possible and cancer
Stringer brought up or one of you a
gentlemen brought up um lighting and I
think although it was considered
um suitable at the moment I don't see
there's any harm in putting another
light on the corner to you from from
Papa John's but
um Let me hear the debate for what other
people think and then they can climb the
fence in safety to um yeah to sum up
yeah I think it improves the area I
think it's um it's something that I
support I don't think it takes anything
away from Ella Turkish because it's it's
such a different
um type of um product that they're
selling and different hours and
everything
um yeah it's um I can't see anything
wrong with this at all in fact uh I
think I am I support it
um
would you like me to propose
um well I'm yeah I'm happy to propose
approval of this application
I would like to speak to the motion and
counselor string of your hands up yeah
thank you I I do think because we're
suggesting that people are going to be
using that lower car park to access this
if they're going to be walking there
they're going to walk up those steps
it's that direct most direct route from
there that actually isn't flat it is
really horrible because you are then
trying to walk on a cambered loading Bay
and I've seen no end of people trip up
and fall over there so there really
ought to be somehow you can walk into
this place flat it isn't good
I've done it myself I've rung my ankle
several times there but because you
didn't need to walk on it so people
actually walk in the middle of the road
to get around that area but now you're
creating an entrance there people will
be trying to walk the most direct route
and you're right James people will walk
back from carbon cut across the through
the vegetation it's already a path there
now and then climb up the stairs and try
and get to that route so the safest way
please so
mean I've parked in the bottom car park
and I've parked in the top and you park
in the top car like you've got the steps
and you turn left there right where that
arrow is just to the left of the arrow
that car that bit of concrete there has
a very sharp downward camber on it and
there's a horrible sort of Junction
between it and the paving on that corner
where that wall is that's a horrible
Junction for any pedestrians but no
questions
but nobody ever walks it because there's
no access there there is now going to be
an access there it's going to be very
very heavily used so it would be really
helpful if there was a path you can see
it there you can actually see the shadow
on the trip Hazard right there
oh I've got you so you can see it's
horrible so so with the proposer in the
secondary could we put a condition in to
level that off somehow or do it would be
it would be good to make sure it's DDA
compliant at least
is that sort of possible sorry I think
that's outside of our red line
unfortunately uh so I think we're gonna
run into difficulty there
um however it's all owned by the council
is it not Amelia the the whole area so I
think we could gladly take that away to
our Essex colleagues and resolve that
way
um and that'd be a note on the on I
think absolutely
Insider knowledge you have to take them
out on site given us this information
absolutely okay second point we are now
introducing hot food takeaway to this
area there is no hot food takeaway
around that area at the moment is there
you know and
no no bye
by Berry Street yes but not directly
from that car park I I do have some
concerns about residential community at
two o'clock in the morning people you
know queuing up for Peter uh and with
and also you've got that mixture of
people using the 24 7 Gym
which is that's why I would really like
to seeing a comment from the police to
say actually these two will rub along
together brilliantly I know we've got
the licensing bit to come but actually
planning is also about
what you use a building for and you try
and iron out crime before you even start
with planning
the the bit I come to those residential
mainly two o'clock in the morning is is
actually really quite late for there to
be a lot of traffic going in and out
of this the gym people will come and go
quite quietly I would imagine
this seems to be a whole other area of
magnitude often peace is delivered not
by cars I mean they they want car
parking spaces for delivery drivers
they're often used mopeds and stuff to
do this with which also are relatively
not noisy they can disturb people and
there's there's residences 26 meters
away from this this is really quite
close so does it really have to be open
until two o'clock in the morning I mean
is there a real need for pizza at two
o'clock in the morning in Stone Market
I'm not is there apparently apparently
there is so I would I was just sort of I
mean for residential amenity purposes I
would have thought midnight was was I
mean what is the restaurant across the
road what are the hours on that one do
we know what what it is
the restaurant across the road is open
until 10 pm from 4 till 10 Tuesday to
Sunday but the nightclub which is
next to the station which is less than
10 minute walk away is open till four
o'clock in the morning and people will
be walking that way through town for the
other takeaway establishments within the
town center of Stone Market and the gym
itself is open 24 7 so they won't be
they won't be walking that way to the
other fast but not at all and we walk
across the pedestrian Crossing and then
turning left into the town
um but also that gym itself is open 24 7
so there are people coming and going on
all kinds of transport
uh 24 7 from there which is directly
next door and I understand it is a bit
further away from the residential houses
but it would be using the same car park
okay well I think we've got the
information that we need to make a
judgment on it
um does it while we're sort of doing
this could before I come back to you
councilor custom is there anyone else
who'd like to speak to the motion
councilor Mellon
have a lineup of a few things thank you
um a couple of points I mean I'm not
quite sure what the overlap is between
gym users and pizza eaters
it's possible that Venn diagram has a
very small bit in the middle but maybe
it balances up you know you eat your
calories and then you work them off
um
yeah yeah I mean the question of
residential means is a concern for me
um yeah as cancer Stringer says often
these deliveries are done by moped I
happen to be in Cambridge on Monday and
I noticed that a lot of those deliveries
were being done by electric scooters and
I don't know if that's something we
could
probably not possible condition but I
mean it um you know would be a good
suggestion for Papa John's or whatever
um the other thing I just wanted to
mention Ed
stand under the original permission for
this being there was supposed to be some
steps at the other end of the building
going down onto gipping way which were
never
um
sort of actually built is there any way
we could check that out because
obviously that would be quite a useful
sort of pedestrian access
and then last lastly it's just that
issue of kind of litter
that they've committed to do a litter
pick between 11 and 12 each morning and
then there's going to be provision of a
bin but that seems to be inside the
customer area
I would have thought that
a customer being outside would perhaps
be more useful in terms of
um you know stopping letter Amelia can
you correct us on that I thought it was
in the car park they were going
to yes it is in the car park and I've
had long talks with the applicant's
agent regarding litter and I'm satisfied
that the litter management plan is
acceptable and it will be covered by
conditions
um and the litter situation will be
reviewed in 12 months after the opening
of The Establishment if permission is
granted
I mean
my experience of when McDonald's open in
Stone Market it wasn't the immediate
area it was when people had finished you
know their their their burger and Chuck
the wrappers out of the window on the
way to Baton so
I don't know what we could do about that
but um obviously that could be part of
the review I guess if Papa John's
packaging has been turning up all over
mid-suffolk um we know you know where
the problem started from
yeah I agree with Council custom that
you know it'd be good to get this
building back into use
and and get that that area working and
and and looking better I think I think
the trip hazards need to be dealt with
if we possibly can
um
but um otherwise just that concern about
residential amenity really that's my
main concern
can I can I ask um councilor Stringer a
question
um
how long does the
because I remember going back to
licensing so infused a burger bar
outside what was oh I don't know what
the name of these nightclubs are carbon
um whatever what time does carbon finish
is my
what time should it fit that's they're
allowed to go until four in the morning
are they indeed okay
um and so that was my question
Outlet out there because again I recall
I'm sorry my memory is not what it used
to be we did restrict certain food yeah
the carbon has its own internal food
preparation yeah okay so question now
now Gemma if the proposer and seconder
are comfortable bearing in mind we know
licensing is different can we alter the
hours in planning now and then as they
apply for a licensing if the licensing
committee decide to amend it again they
can so as they wish
yes you can apply whatever condition you
feel comfortable with normal tests of
condition reasonable necessary and so on
what I would just say is
um planning and Licensing they need both
so we can well we know yeah so just that
if licensing go out later and we've said
midnight then you'll have to come back
and adjust it yeah but it might give
Comfort to us as planners yes we've
perhaps reduce hours because because it
has been mentioned as a time what do the
proposer and seconders think about us
being able to do that bearing in mind
that you're also on the last thing
fine line between licensing and planning
I think my my main concern here and I
presume this is really more of a
licensing issue the other establishment
is the main Ipswich Street they do stay
open much later than two o'clock well
that can come under license but I'm
talking about planning here today to
planners would they feel more
comfortable if a decision was made to
reduce the hour I'm seeing councilor
Castle
um I wouldn't be more con um comfortable
I think that's something for licensing I
think that people need to sit in a
committee room with all the information
in front of them in regards to that
um
one thing um I don't know from these
plans if the wool
um the sort of appear or whatever you
call it coming off
that building and whether that's been
removed it looks like it is being
removed but I'm just I'm just thinking
that that's um
if that's turning into a um Pizza
can you have you got that
I can see exactly what you mean I'm on
slide four on page 52 and there does
appear to be more of a pier and then a
there I call it wiggly line coming away
from it you couldn't pop it up could you
could you pop it up
brilliant thank you it's yeah you just
see it on the right there and that um
that goes about I don't know
eight meters maybe not quite six meters
um out to the um towards the car park
it's right in the corner of that photo
um on the right hand side
um
people are gonna sit on that and eat
their food and it's potentially going to
call some people to um
confront each other but eat their food
drop food fall off backwards and bang
their heads I don't know if that's going
to be taken away it looks like it's been
taken away but I think it'd be a really
good idea to to remove that
I'd like to put that to the committee
and see what they've used about it
um
if um I what I what I'll do is I'll
condition it now but when we talk about
the proposal if anyone thinks it's
something they can talk to them yeah
they can talk to it but I yeah I think
that's got to go because it
yeah right sorry Mike I would propose an
informative as opposed to a condition if
we're comfortable with that just because
of our red line situation we're sort of
getting into knots that are more
difficult to deal with and bearing in
mind it is Council owned land that I
feel would give us the security today
that we could take that away separately
rather than a specific condition if
that's acceptable right so does anyone
else wish to speak to the motion that
we've got on the table now which is a
recommendation yes Council of all boys
thank you
we'll look at this wall in the raised
curve uh it and and strangely enough
there is a little a man walking down
that side of the road so he's actually
across this uh raised curb and going
down to the other car park
um
I think
um
I would just like to be really clear in
my mind I think that race Kirk should be
removed I think the wall could be
shortened and I think in order to sort
of make that
area safer there should be some sort of
additional lighting to make sure it's
actually clear and it may actually
[Music]
um
stop people loitering eye and my concern
is less cancer wall boys we can do the
lighting but the other bit is outside
our it's outside this application we're
going to put a note an informative note
land but that's outside this application
but but the lighting we can ask for a
light to go on the corner of Papa John's
because that's within it
would you know and then
the members are going to take it away as
mid-suffer go into the land to try and
get those other issues which everybody
has just spoken about okay yeah fair
enough yes
thank you Council Stringer we must move
on yeah of course I just want to help
yeah your red line doesn't allow you to
do anything with that wall uh or even
the front Piers of the building because
it's not in the red line what I don't
understand is difficult so obviously the
applicant has served a note is on
mid-suffolk but there's no blue line
here because normally the ownership of
this is all one person
which is this Council but what's odd is
we're not allowed to then condition
anything in a blue line because there
isn't a blue line because it's not
within the gift of the applicant even
though we own the site the applicants on
that's really if it should have been our
application we'd have been able to
condition what was in the blue line
because Widow had to declare that blue
line so that's that's all a bit messy
just to say to Cason you can't take the
wall away because it's holding up the
the footpath it because of that radical
difference in height if you took it away
you've got a mass you'll fall into the
loading Bay because it is it is probably
about a meter deep at that point so
perhaps we ought to just leave the
opposite to look to see how an
improvement if anything the wall ought
to go higher to stop you being able to
sit on it or throw anything I said about
railings or something an informative
note I think we've done this one to
death at the moment
so
um we have a proposal and a seconder
with an additional light was that one of
the things and two informative notes of
which one was the wall one was the curb
um
I also think I think it was councilman
said that
originally there was a footpath meant to
come around the back of to inquire
whether that's but yeah because that
brings people away from those houses
that are going up there if they're if
they are going the roadway have you got
that
I have I'm just trying to phrase the
position of that footpath so it's to the
rear of
the rear of things do you want to know
what three yeah no I don't need to go
that far just
um it's the other end of the building
the other end of the building going down
to the right of the pure gym entrance it
would take you into the that bottom car
park and then you've got stairs coming
up already for the um from the lower car
park into the into that area it would
just be a um a um some way of getting
through into that car park
um early on
um
yeah no I think it's exactly okay so
yeah no that's fine so um yeah we've got
the recommendation on page 35 with an
additional condition for additional
lighting and an informative and I've
used the word to address so whether
that's removed higher different but
essentially to address that problem on
the water adjacent to the entrance and
the curb and the bridge of the footpath
to the rear of the building adjacent to
the podium entrance are you happy that
that would be an informative to us
internally or would you like that on the
decision
yep fun
can I just clarify my understanding and
it may well be wrong but I'm sure
somewhere in the planning department
there is this document there was
supposed to be a set of steps going down
the the right the other end of the
building down to gipping way
no but I think they said at the rear and
going down to the lower carpet I think
it was straight from gipping away uh up
to
uh to the right at the entrance of the
pure gym
it's not the rear though it's the side
side okay
sorry it's a diaper don't you
but it's adjacent to the pure Joe
entrance if I just leave it as adjacent
is that is that close enough I think
Amelia seems to know well
the vote then please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress it will be showing us blue
on your app and it will be above the
last vote that we just did
comes with a Stringer
oh that's fine thank you
no that's fine
thank you chest that is eight votes for
so that is unanimous thank you very much
yeah what's the word I'm looking for
interest that the counselor has and
unfortunately uh councilor Gould has to
leave us as well so thank you very much
for your input
and we're just checking we are still
core despite um Ward members and um
other members leaving
foreign
who's going to present our final case
today which is where are you
[Applause]
dc2106824 lands no it isn't that one
it's the next one
it is
[Applause]
blacksmiths Road cotton
which is DC
2201535 so if you'd like to present the
case thank you guys
thank you
yes um this is an outline application
with all matters reserved so at a minute
we have no details with regards to scale
design or style of the dwelling or where
all the situated so we just have the red
line
um I think it's important to to inform
the committee in the public that the
reason why this has come back to
committee is that previously
um officers report failed to mention
that this this house would be a
self-built plot
um and that's why it's come back to
committee
um I'll give you some information about
that but first I'm going to go through
the presentation
so the application site is situated in
the countryside
and as you can see the character of
society is semi-rural it becomes quite
open and exposed to the South and
Southeast
it has a road Frontage but we have no
detail with regards to access access is
reserved
but is relatively a
straight stretch of roads so probably
slightly the visibility displays could
could be achieved
this is a wider context of the site
and also this is the red line and the
relationship between the nearest
built up environment
you can see the settlements of cotton
and bactin on either side of the
application site it's in fact closer to
bactin than it is to Cotton but in any
case it's situated in an open
Countryside and belongs to neither
consider visibility displays
demonstrated here this is again to
reiterate this is the only information
we have available at hand
and these are some photos taken from
various points
on Blacksmith Lane
as you can see it's quite uh quite rural
in character
especially on this side of the
Blacksmith Lane
um office's recommendation is refusal
nothing has changed in terms of our
assessment and our considerations for
policy
consideration has been given to the fact
that this is a self-built plot and there
is a specially Duty upon the local
governments to local authorities to to
have regards to
um to self-build and custom build plots
and to keep a register
this application around the applicant is
not on the register but that that
doesn't mean that you know we wouldn't
accept that this is a self-built plot
um
however or have outlined in in offices
report how we calculate self-built plots
and the fact that we have indeed
exceeded the requirement for our self-bu
plants and custom Loop plots within the
district
it is also important to note that we
have well over excessive
um nine year of supply of housing
and this does not preclude self-build
and custom build plots so that's
included in the data
I think the only period-based period
that we haven't met the requirement for
self-build and custom build plots is
base period six however the way these
are calculated without going into too
much technical details is every three
years and at the minute we are in the
first 12 months of the base period six
and we have already met a third of the
requirement that we needed to meet and
as I said um I have included all the
data that we have obtained from our
strategic housing um
for for your viewing and
so just wanted to say that this does not
change
our recommendation or our position in
terms of policy consideration policy
context and the recommendation is to
still refusal of this application that
is in a sustainable location thank you
very much
thank you for that does anyone have any
questions
nope in that case then there's nobody
else here may we go into debate please
oh sorry oh forgot about you I do beg
your partner would you like to tell us
your side of this I'll keep it brief
chair thank you
um so yeah I'm on the uh board member
for cotton and this this site is within
cotton Parish
um this application came before
committee back in July I'm sure we'll
remember that and since I thought it had
been determined then I didn't keep the
note of what I said last time
um so I then went to the council's
website to look at the recording so I
didn't contradict myself but
unfortunately that meeting was in a room
where we didn't have a recording
equipment so I'm attempting to sort of
recreate what I said last time
I think the main points were that
um cotton is designated as Countryside
in the emerging joint like called plan
even if we go back to the existing
policy framework this site is outside
the settlement boundary as the officer
has shown
and we have recent decisions in the
immediate area
which have included a refusal of a
proposal for 12 homes opposite cotton
village hall in part due to it being an
unsustainable location
we do have a lot of Development coming
to my ward but that's all in back to
where the services are cotton is you
know a mile or so away from that so the
argument I think is that this is
Services people would be dependent or
car
I do know this site well although I
didn't have a specific site visit to it
this is a as you've seen from the slides
a very well vegetated site and if we to
give permission here it would have been
a loss of basically what is a
species-rich Woodland area
um the question about self-build I mean
clearly I support self-builders it's a
sustainable way for people to be able to
you know forward and build their own
home but there have been quite a number
of self-build sites even along this
piece of road in the past
um sites have gained permission when we
didn't have a five-year land Supply
so this one I think doesn't Stand Out
particularly as being one that that
benefits um
you know the the land Supply
um even though it's self-built there is
provision for these elsewhere in the
district
um
so I'm sort of against development on
this site
thank you
thank you very much indeed any questions
for the ward member
a case we can now go into debate thank
you for your information
thank you very much
thank you
in view of what the big planning officer
and also the war member said he's
against this application and therefore I
would actually move that we refuse it as
as requested by the planning office
report
thank you for that councilor Norris
thank you very much indeed councilor
Norris
um I think there's nothing more to be
said if we're all happy with that may we
go to the vote please
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
foreign
Norris
it's fine
that's just come through thank you uh so
chair because Council gold has left and
councilman and Stringer can't vote um we
only have five votes on this item and
that has been five votes for so that is
unanimous
which indeed
um so we now come to the end of the
meeting do we have any site inspections
none received here and the next meeting
of DCB is the 23rd of November so thank
you very much for everybody's
participation today thank you